un sol radiante y una alegría desbordada
fue lo que se percibió en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires desde muy temprano cuando
miles de personas se agruparon en las
principales calles y avenidas para ver
así sea por un breve tiempo a sus nuevos
Héroes los integrantes de la selección
de fútbol de Argentina ganadora de la
Copa del Mundo de Qatar
no pensaba de vivir algo así este año le
teníamos
mucha voz y por suerte se dio gracias
[Música]
por toda la felicidad que nos trajo por
la lucha que es una inolvidable el más
grande El más grande que fue El Diego
está en el cielo y ahora la copa que no
trajo Leonel Andrés Messi con el título
en Qatar Argentina ha ganado tres copas
la primera en 1978 y la segunda en 1986
para quienes han vivido los triunfos
anteriores Este título tiene algo
especial por las dificultades que padece
el pueblo argentino la de pues máximo
pero era muy chica tenía 11 años o sea
que esta ya con 47 años es un pudor me
parte el alma
inolvidable se ve en la gente en el
sufrimiento que tiene la gente y hoy
festejar esto es espectacular por 29
días los colores que unieron a la
sociedad Argentina fueron el Celeste y
el blanco muchos desean que esta Unión
pueda consolidarse para otras causas
es un sentimiento muy grande como se
unen los argentinos para festejar me
gustaría mucho que también lo hagamos
para para otras cosas son muy
importantes como la contaminación
calentamiento global dentro de las
particularidades que ofreció la Copa del
Mundo de Qatar se suma la celebración
Argentina ya que por primera vez su
fanáticos pudieron festejar con la
llegada del verano